let's now look at some of the guests at
this completely delusional Trump rally
over the weekend we already looked at
Trump's speech in Florence South
Carolina uh these are some of my
favorite Clips these are people who went
to the rally I guess we kind of have to
start with he's sort of just a guest at
the end of the day my pillow CEO and
founder Mike Lindell he was just roaming
around the the fairgrounds or the
campground or whatever it is where they
had the rally
and he has some new claims about 2020.
it's not even worth introducing them
let's just listen to what he had to say
you know where the most boats in the
United the states were sold sold anyone
want to guess California 1.5 million
votes were stolen from Donald Trump
folks they were stoled they stole them
and they are not giving them back the
second in the nation the tie between
Texas and Florida almost a million votes
each okay so you can come over for these
red States right Alabama
um John Merrill the Secretary of State
there John I'm coming for you I'm coming
for there coming back for the fourth
time we found now where all the crime
was there the in the machines and stuff
in Alabama a hundred and five thousand
votes Ohio 120 000 Bulls Donald Trump
won you want to hear what states we know
he won here's the states that Donald
Trump won for sure this should be good
sure he won he won Minnesota Wisconsin
Michigan Pennsylvania New Hampshire
um Georgia Georgia
Arizona and Nevada we don't know about
he might have won Maine he might have
won Colorado there's four others yeah
Colorado question mark you know it's
funny even if 1.5 million votes in
California were stoled
um Biden won there by 5.1 million votes
so as absurd it's like there's three
layers of absurdity here as absurd as
the claim is about 1.5 million votes
being stoled or stolen as I would say
for which there's no evidence
it also wouldn't even change the results
in California I mean I don't know here
is probably my favorite clip from the
rally this is a woman who has been
dubbed Gigi the Greek goddess
and she says Communism is here in the
United States now one of the things I
love is she and the interviewer agree
communism is here but they don't agree
about how it got here this is the I love
when there's confusion like this
the Greek goddess say that communism is
here because the US the American people
are loud are allowed to bring communism
to this country we're allowing it to
come in this country we're not missing
it right but and we're allowed this is
the best she says aloud he says we're
allowing and then it just gets more and
more confusing so what do they do they
call for everyone to be imprisoned for
treason people the Americans not to
stand up and fight for our country
they're beautiful country of ours and
yes they stole our elections right big
Tech Soros the demoras the Republicans
the demon rats and Soros stole the
election guys they stole it oh they're
still elections swamp needs to go
this one I love your shirt there you go
turn around oh all right there you go
and baby because the guy the guy he is
more than that he needs to be in jail
for treason all of them
the joy in the hall got to go
yes Biden put him in prison for treason
she says then trumps uh uh Trump's
endorsed candidate to fight against uh
Nancy mace Trump wants Nancy mace out
and instead he's endorsed uh Kate
Arrington here K Arrington gives us her
four policy priorities so it's like oh
hey we're gonna get some policy from
Republicans that's cool let's listen
listen to her four priorities
country first things we need to do when
we get up there fire fouchy second thing
get rid of the Department of federal
education and third thing start
impeaching Biden and open Huntington
Biden's laptop uh
um yeah that these are her legislative
priorities fire fauci fauci's 80 and I'm
sure is retiring soon number two get rid
of the Department of Education this is
the opposite of what we need we we need
to we need to save American public
education impeach Biden she doesn't say
For What and four open up Hunter Biden's
laptop now I don't know if she means
just like turn it on and open the lid or
if she means like take it apart or just
access the contents it's not really
clear what what she means and then
lastly just to round out the tone and
tenor of this wacky Trump rally in South
Carolina here's a guy who said he
refuses to wear masks so he's not flying
because if he flew he would have have to
punch the stewardess
wow
[Laughter]
and I'm definitely not getting
vaccinated
so kill him he'll he'll die before he
gets a vaccine and he'll punch he says
stewardess he'll punch a flight
attendant uh before he puts on a mask so
really the caliber of folks that are
they're not going ironically to the
rally understand that if they went
ironically it would be a totally
different thing but they are
unironically at the rally
we're going to take a break all of these
clips will be on our Facebook
facebook.com slash davidpackman show
I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is Helix sleep I sleep on
a helix mattress at home I absolutely
love it and that's why I reached out to
them about sponsoring the David packman
show buying a mattress in the past was
always a huge guessing game for me I
didn't know what I actually needed I
didn't know what I would like but Helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress Helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired Magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every Helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but I know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to 200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free when you
go to the link right underneath this
video